-Welcome back.
We're here with Dan Levy.
And we are about to play a
brand-new game called
"Best, Worst, First."
-♪ Best ♪
♪ Worst ♪
♪ First ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
I'll hit this button here,
which activates
a random topic generator.
It will land
on a random prompt,
like "Best pick-up line
you have ever used"
or "Worst lie you
ever have told."
Whatever it lands on,
you have to tell the first story
or memory that comes to
our minds.
Are you ready for this?
-Okay. Yeah, I'm ready.
-Alright, first up is "Best."
[ Beeping ]
Best late-night snack.
Alright, I got one.
-Ooh!
-Dan, what is yours?
-Okay. I have recently
been doing --
I can only do a savory and
a sweet together.
So I have been doing gummies
that I put in the refrigerator,
because I like them
cold and chewy,
and then I do a popcorn.
And, recently, my friend got me
onto nutritional yeast,
so I have been doing, like, a
nutritional-yeast popcorn.
And I was eating
my gummies and popcorn,
and it was kind of,
I would imagine,
lit only by the refrigerator,
looked like a
really intense late-night binge.
And then I looked out my window,
and there was someone
just really concerned
staring back at me
from the apartment
just across the way, so if you
are going to late-night-snack,
maybe lower the blinds,
unless you want
to just entertain people,
or, in her case, I think she was
looking at me like,
"Poor thing."
-My late-night snack is --
What I do is,
if I ever get pizza, I order
pizza, I order two pies.
The second pie,
I take out individual slices,
put them in Ziploc bags,
and freeze them.
And then, when I feel like
a late-night snack,
I throw it in the toaster oven.
And I know how to
zhuzh it up perfect,
and it tastes like
a fresh slice.
-Hot tips.
-Welcome back to "Hot Tips."
Okay, here we go.
Next round,
it's time for the worst.
Here we go. Worst!
-Alright.
[ Beeping ]
Okay. Worst fear. Dan.
-I'll just --
I have no shame about this.
My worst fear is
moths and butterflies,
which is a strange --
It's a strange fear to have.
-That's the worst fear
of all of the fears?
-Listen, I'm owning it.
They have powdery,
very weird wings
and they don't fly
in any particular direction.
And that -- Yeah, it's that.
It's the frantic
kind of flapping.
-Yes, it's the flapping.
-Inevitably, I think they're
going to end up in my mouth.
I can't rationalize
this fear, Jimmy.
-Wow.
-All I can do is
share it with you tonight.
-Last round,
it's time for "First."
[ Beeping ]
First concert?
First...acting credit.
That's interesting.
Dan, first acting credit.
-My first big opportunity was
playing a murderous tech person
in a Lifetime film where I was
out to murder Mischa Barton.
-What?!
-And -- Yeah.
And the fun plot twist
is that we realized
that I actually had
also murdered her parents.
But anyone who watches
this Lifetime movie,
if they were to actually put
the pieces together,
would realize that,
in terms of the timeline
of this character's life,
I had to have
murdered her parents when I was
about 10 1/2 years old.
So I don't want to say that
this movie is a masterpiece
or anything,
but it's certainly something
that shaped my career in really
pivotal and fundamental ways.
-I feel like we get
Blumhouse on this
and remake this into
a giant feature film.
I'm into it.
-It would be a tough pitch.
-First acting credit, weirdly,
because, tonight, we also have
the great Michael J. Fox
on the show,
his show "Spin City."
-Canadian legend.
-He is a Canadian legend.
-Mm-hmm.
-"Spin City."
I was on an episode of
"Spin City."
I auditioned in New York City.
And I played
a photographer that, like,
took a Polaroid picture
of, like --
And I was so excited for
the audition,
I went in and
I had this weird jacket
that I got at
a store called Structure
that doesn't exist anymore.
I don't know if you
remember that.
And I had this jacket on
and this sweater,
and I went in
and I got the audition.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
I go, "When do I go in for
wardrobe or who do I meet?"
Blah, blah, blah.
And they go, "Just wear exactly
what you wore in the audition."
Dude, I'm going to
find that movie,
and we got to talk more about
that when you come back.
-Please don't.
-I'm psyched about your new
movie, "Happiest Season,"
is available on Hulu
November 25th.